hi my name is taylor tomlinson and i
feel braggadocious about being conan
o'brien's friend that's a very good one
that's a really good one try bragging
about it though it's not going to oh i
have oh you haven't i have yeah i sent
it to my sibling group chat this morning
which is very active and my youngest
sister wrote back in all caps holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
say hi to sona for me i love her so much
and matt my idols and then in lower case
love conan too
that was a body blow that was a punch
that was a punch to the solar plexus
and um i wasn't prepared for it so all
the wind has gone out of me now i liked
it yeah it's uh i get it i get it uh no
it's very helpful because a lot of
people ask like have you done any cool
shows like when people don't know that
you're successful they're like have you
done any cool gigs and you're like kind
of
and going on tour with you is always my
answer oh that's nice yeah thank you
it's really nice we had a blast it was
so much fun um i don't know what your
memories are of of that but i'll just
bring people up to date we did uh was i
want to say this is before covet 2018
2018 and maybe the cause of kovid we're
not
[Laughter]
and then there's the conan tour theory
uh it was weird at a lab on the private
i had i'm constantly
constantly doing experiments um
with weird viruses
just work on yourself yeah just hey
tighten up that ending
okay once you worry about your stuff and
let me worry about these bat viruses
that i'm concocting
yeah we
we all have hobbies okay those are
hobbies that's my hobby uh
yeah i need to be more careful about
keeping that [ __ ] in the lab but anyway
we went on this tour and i remember my
my distinct memory of you was um i would
say most of the audiences were really
good yeah and they were really terrific
audiences wherever we went
but i remember you just being absolutely
fearless in a way that blew me away
because you're so young oh thank you and
i was very impressed i was like this
this person doesn't know fear or is not
showing it that you have fear
but you would go out there and you would
kill it
and um
you had a sense of
purpose that i found to be incredibly
impressive and and
you know
you're
like a third my age and i just was blown
away by that you know i've actually done
the math have you yeah yeah i'm 79
and you were 11 on that trip
yeah i was like is conan 90
[Laughter]
you're going to really love her
unlike some of us she didn't fight in a
korean war
yeah i think i was 24 at the time and
what i've found is that if you start
really young people are
very impressed with you even if you are
trash so i you know who knows how good i
actually was but it's like when you see
like a dog skateboard
and you're like he's not supposed to be
able to do that yeah is he a good
skateboarder it's like no he's a dog but
he's doing it he's doing it yeah which
is more than we ever thought he could do
um i'm not gonna say you were a dog on a
skateboard i'm not gonna say that uh
you're a hilarious comedian and um one
of the things that impressed me is we we
talked a bunch of times
and
your work ethic
and the
the
uh i don't want to say pressure you put
on yourself you have a very high
standard which i found
to be incredibly impressive oh thank you
well again when you're younger in this
business i think you
get certain opportunities when you're
young and you want to prove that you're
worthy of them so that's certainly an
aspect of it that contributed to that
pressure and then also i just you know
want to be really good at my job i think
it's more fun when you're really good
uh
but yeah i i mean that tour was so
insane
because i remember like the first night
maybe we all had dinner and you like
pulled me aside afterward and made a
point to be like hey just so you know
really glad you're here you deserve to
be here like you kind of picked up on my
imposter syndrome i feel like right and
made a point to be very encouraging uh
which i think you did with everyone i've
heard um
not with funches
well he's very confident yeah he's an
imposter
i know we all feel like we're imposters
but you punches no i absolutely uh
i'm picking on this guy because i
absolutely adore him but
um first of all you showed up for the
tour and you were sick oh yeah this was
back when it was impressive to push
through an illness yes again 2018. i
think i had like the flu the first leg
of the tour and i came back the second
week and everyone was like nice to meet
you
because the first week i was just in so
much pain i was trying not to even drink
water because we were on a private jet
with conan o'brien and i'm like i can't
be in this bathroom can i say the most
impressive thing yes we got a jet for
certain legs of the trip you know to to
get us from here to there but we the
economics of the tour was yeah this is
how it's going to work if there's 11 of
us on a private plane this can all work
so we did that and about halfway through
the tour i remembered you guys saying so
conan
um when you bought this jet yeah did you
how did you pick out this wood grain and
i said wait what
you guys were like when you bought this
jet and i remembered um i think it was
saying to you i said this is not my jet
yeah we're
we're leasing this jet for this tour
because the tour is hoping to pay for it
but i fly commercial i don't have a jet
what ma and i said to you what made you
think that i have a jet and you said
well you've been on television my whole
life
and i'm like
so therefore you must have a jet i'm
like are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah no
my jet is american airlines
hi american
i remember that like a little less
change conan doesn't have a private jet
who the [ __ ] does well i have i say like
this is a thing with me as i see people
um
and i know that it's a big sign of
success with like instagram
people and influencers that you fly
around on a private jet
and i always tell people do you know
what that [ __ ] costs oh yeah and you're
going to none of your children will ever
go to college if you're flying around on
those things it's not going to happen so
i'm very happy to hitch a ride with
someone or if the tour will pay for it
great it's lovely
but um i just knew when there was that
moment where you guys were like oh so
conan's jet's pretty nice oh yeah we all
thought that was your jet i should have
cut my mouth shut yeah you should have
and i should have worn a big fur coat
the whole time you should have i and i
remember too
we were all scared to take the photo in
front of the jet but we wanted it
obviously the minute we saw the jet we
were like we're all gonna get a picture
in front of this jet right right but we
were like it has to be a group photo we
have to time it so i think we waited
until like the last day maybe of the
first leg and i remember ron was the one
who was like yeah we're taking a picture
in front of the jet of course and we
were like oh thank god okay let's just
do it
and we were also like can we ask conan
to be in the photo is it like is that
okay like i don't know i don't know if
any but i guess flula probably knew you
the best of anybody but i certainly i
had only met you for
moments on your show yeah and so i
didn't know what you were gonna be like
and i remember saying just like why is
conan like hanging out with us
like did your respect for me drop
plummet oh yeah of course
the veil was pulled back and i said
maybe he's not as talented as i thought
he was
if he's rubbing shoulders with us